and they're like Joe Biden got 81
million votes I'm like really he got
more than Obama like Obama was a really
popular guy they had obey t-shirts with
Obama on it there's no obey with Biden
on it there's no Biden merch
[Music]
dude what's up everybody and we are back
with special episode numero do of the
careful boys featuring Mr Matt Kim in
the building today thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
man we honestly I got to say after the
billions upon billions of videos that we
shoot here our last video that we just
shot with you is one of the most focused
and engaging ones we've had in a
conversation a lot of time probably
because we never get free thinking
speech uh and Truth here we're always
doing nothing but [__] Echo chamber
stuff what are you talking about it's
kind of our style yeah it's kind of our
thing um but yo uh the last thing we had
just talked about was you know the
different people that have been reaching
out to you in the last 6 months of
snowballing a crazy lifestyle you just
had uh uh you tuck Tucker Carlson's team
reached out and you you had him on a pod
that pod was crazy by the way it was
kind of dope just watching you guys Rift
about stuff um and then Joe even
mentioned that he's not seeing as many
people from the left reach out and you
had just made a point about people from
the extreme right also not really liking
your stuff so like how do you feel about
like the amount of people that are
listening do you feel like this is giant
kind of huge populace that does want to
be in this freethinking
anti-establishment type of space but
like doesn't necessarily have a spot to
go to or like what is the what are the
main themes and beliefs that everybody
in that space has I think there is a
huge community of people I think the
majority of the country they're like
something is not right here there is
something that's not right with what's
going on in the world like why is the
media just propaganda telling us what to
believe and they're just lying to us now
they used to be deceitful now they're
just blatantly lying blatant lies
why do the leaders that are supposed to
represent us why are they sitting there
controlling us and trying to tell us how
to live our lives shout outs to fouchy
right can we get some of your your
specifics the what are like I don't know
like maybe some of the top three lies
direct lies that you feel like we're
being all right are you guys ready to
get demonetized yep let's do it oh we
were never we were never monetized yeah
oh we don't make money here 2 minutes
let's go Are We There Yet awesome
awesome so well the first one is the
obvious one right they told us that Co
came from bats like that was obviously
[__] cuz there was a China man with
a bat skewer going I like a bat I saw
that
guy they showed the videos over and over
again of the girl eating the bats
remember that video that was so weird
the Batgirl and you bat girl and anyone
bat girl movie at the same time by the
way they did they had a scrap it they
spent like 200 mil I'm not saying
they're correlated no that was
correlated n dude for sure maybe it has
to be like bad PR they spent like $120
million on that [__] hell money on it
yeah and they scrapped it it was like
the same time not even one deleted
scenes on the market dude they only had
the costume that made it would have done
successful dude it would have [__]
back girl hey backgirl we got to watch
it derailed anyways yeah but that was
the that was the most obvious one right
because anyone that said wait a second
that doesn't seem right like oh no you
can't say that you're conspiracy
theorist get off the internet and people
like wait what that was weird like you
were told that was so crazy and then
they're like and then they told you that
vaccines are
99.9% effective it's a good number and
people are like wo really okay but you
have to take it wait I have to why do I
have to can't sue yeah can't sue if
something goes wrong and that was I
think the eye opening part for a lot of
it right because you were told one thing
and anyone that questioned otherwise
which all we now know that actually
actually the conspiracy theorists were
WR about 100% of it that they used to
say like things like hydroch chloroquin
and um what's the other one like these
things are I the horse tranquilizer
these are bad for and then you find out
like actually they're pretty effective
that there's a lot of people that still
take it to this day and that they
recover really fast from taking it like
this wasn't conspiracy theorist that it
actually does work and people like you
guys are crazy like wait a second
there's like 3,000 like you have to
trust this science trust the scientists
and wait a second but there are
scientists why do we have to trust your
scientists but I can't trust these
scientist and then you had that guy
Robert Malone he's the biologist that
developed the technology he came out and
said no like you should be careful here
not saying you shouldn't take it but
it's fair to ask questions and they're
like no get off the internet we're like
wait what I want to hear what he has to
say can I hear more about this I
invented the MRNA technology and then
everyone's like n conspiracy he goes no
it was me dude and I don't think mRNA
vaccines are good he goes n get out of
here and they said you know trust a
scientist and then 3,000 scientists got
together and said wait a second like we
don't like this and like oh no don't
trust those scientists like what what
who decides which scientist you can
listen to and I think that was kind of
the first eye opening moment for a lot
of people right and then you have the
election sorry guys you have the
election right and they're like you know
and part of the country is like well it
was a fraudulent
election and then yell the other side
say no like it was the most free and
fair election
ever ever the most free and they're like
Joe Biden got 81 million votes I'm like
really he got more than Obama like Obama
was a really popular guy they had obey
t-shirts with Obama
on there's no obey with Biden on it
there's no Biden merch he got more than
Kelly Clarkson and American Idol one by
the way Obama had murals all over the
country I don't see one Biden he
couldn't lose bro there's no way there's
not what there's like there's still
Obama murals till this day they love
like people loved Obama right right and
you see and then you saw the Trump
rallies with tens of thousands of people
there and then I'm I'm sorry tens of
thousands of super spreaders there and
then how dare they and then you had the
Biden event with six people in circles 6
feet apart
and they're like 81 million votes and
people like I can't believe you're
questioning the election I'm like I
think it's fair that people question the
election and by the way they act like
this is the first time an election was
questioned I mean when Bush won right um
you know I voted for John krey and you
know at the time everybody was
questioning the digital election
computers um which by the way they use
the same computers in somewhere in
Southeast Asia for election fraud and
and yeah the so George W bush won and
you know all of us the Democrats at the
time everybody would they wouldn't let
that go and they would say that was a
stolen election and so I'm like don't
act like this is the first time
someone's coming out and questioning the
election cuz it was done during the Bush
Administration too don't they question
it every single elction they do it all
the [__] time so then people are now
saying like well if you question it then
you're also an insurrectionist and I'm
all like I'm not that [__] old dude
and I
remember the that was one of the first
elections I got you know I I I was a
part of and and you know I we thought
that bush stole it so I'm like I don't
know yeah it's just weird to me it is
your right as an American to question
the election you have every right to do
so and anyone that tells you that you
don't have the ability to or you can't
they are Fascist because they can't do
that it's your freedom of speech you can
question whatever you want and that was
weird right right and then even in the
Trump indictments in Washington Jack
Smith who is a special prosecutor he
said that there was not outcome
determinate fraud that's the exact
phrase there was fraud in the election
100% it's just not outcome determinate
fraud according to the US government
okay fine then how much fraud is too
much
fraud there's fraud but not that much
what what did take place right no nobody
knows if they can't say how much fraud
was fraud then how dare you say you're
questioning the election you have if you
can't tell me how much fraud there was
how do you know that there was not
enough fraud to be outcome determined
that's
[__] that's like those apple things
that say like assembled in China but
made in America or something it's like I
don't know where it's really made it's a
little bit of both yeah we'll take it
how much fraud was there was there one
vote 10 votes 100 votes a th000 votes a
million votes if you you don't know how
do you know there wasn't enough I think
these are very fair questions and I
think that was a really big thing for a
lot of people I think even people who
support or anti-trump as they start
unraveling it they're like you're right
like how much fraud was there so I think
that was a big one I think the third big
one is this whole January 6th inter
Insurrection narrative sorry guys this
is probably the one that's going to get
you kicked
off
delete
this you hey cam delete this now we are
let me tell you we are the Cockroaches
of YouTube we keep any nuclear disasters
we [__] survive them all they're
going to tune into here during a nuclear
disas this may have to go on the
patreon the Insurrection I watched it
live like a lot of people did on TV
right they called an Insurrection what
is an Insurrection what is an
Insurrection by legal definition right
it is a organized attempt organized
armed attempt to overthrow government
that's the legal St that's a legal
standard for an Insurrection you have to
prove all three that it was organized
number one number two that it was armed
number three they were trying to
overthrow government they actually can't
prove either or but yet they call it
Insurrection Insurrection Insurrection
Insurrection we hear that every single
day I've had the opportunity to speak to
a lot of people that were part of that
event I actually even did a um episode
with the kunon shaman which is crazy oh
the furry hat guy isn't he in jail well
he's out now oh okay I I was so curious
because in my mind they tell me that he
is this crazy radical that is trying to
overthrow the government and he was one
of the people that led the charge to
overthrow the government he looks like
he really likes
Sports he them Dallas Cowboys is he kind
of a conspiracy theorist yes but so am I
is he crazy and extreme definitely not
like like there's nothing and he is
extremely smart and intelligent like he
speaks extremely well and I was shocked
by how well spoken he is and how well
thought his ideas were he actually spent
his time in jail um doing teachings and
trainings with fellow inmates and
helping them get through their drug
rehab wow so like he spent his time in
jail as best he could which I thought
was pretty cool of him he is not this
crazy like I'm trying to overthrow the
government guy that people portray him
to be and once I saw that I was like man
that's that's a different one but the
the question that really messed a lot of
people up when they talk Insurrection is
how did the Insurrection
end do you guys know how it ended no no
I just saw videos of what it looked like
the security walking people in so like
the narrative is they stormed it you
know and then you see all these videos
of like them kind of just talking oh
this there's a video of them a cop
opening the door and then going like
this they're walking together like he's
showing them the hallway talking like
nothing how the they look like friends
yeah yeah there's actually a congressman
from the oversight committee I can't
think of his name right now um that went
the record and said that he 100%
believes that there were 200 plus FBI
agents within the capital that day
dressed as Trump supporters guiding them
in wow and because if you've ever been
to the capital and if anyone watching
has ever been to the capital that place
is a labyrinth it is hallway after
hallway after turn after turn you don't
just walk in the front door and all of a
sudden know where Nancy Pelosi's office
is like it's impossible there's so many
turns and the and they're not like
labeled like hey you know you know take
a left here to Nancy p off like it
doesn't
exist he left to the
Heavies heavies here yeah it doesn't
exist he believes 100% that there was
200 plus FBI agents guiding people
through the capital that day it was a
setup damn so the question is how did
the Insurrection end and nobody knows
because if it was an organized armed
attempt to overthrow government someone
would have waved the White Flag hey I
Surrender or whatever and you have Al
doing that video of like people were
banging on the bathroom door that she
was scared for her life because she
thought she was going to die they
probably needed to poop real bad yeah
you have all these congressmen talking
about how they were so scared and they
thought their lives were over right if
it was that extreme of a situation how
did it end and people no one knows yeah
of all this coverage on January 6th how
come no one knows how it ended that's
true cuz we should see some footage of
put your hands up [__] uh we
surrender yeah but there was there's no
like official announcement of surrender
or anything and then we didn't see like
bus loads of people getting like sent to
jail they just fizzled out the whole
they just walked away how do the people
that you talked to that were there the
Insurrection ended because in Washington
DC there was a 6:30 curfew and everyone
went home by curfew what are you going
to tell me that an armed organized
attempt to overthrow government ended at
curfew yes because when there's gun free
zones I go oh [__] let me go put this
gun away I didn't see that sign they
went home by curfew wow so they're like
hey guys uh White House is closed at
6:30 and then they're like nobody told
me this rule man [__] a [__] we can't
[__] take over the government they
all went home at
630 wow they were all cleared out and do
you know when Congress went back in
session they were back they were back in
session by 7:00 p.m. and they were
voting by 7:30 wow so if they thought
that their lives were in danger
that these people were storming the
capital to end their
lives Congress they're cowards there is
no way they stay in that building they
went home and they would have been like
let's start this again tomorrow we got
to make sure that the whole perimeter is
clear that there's no one hiding like
they would have shut down everything
they were back in session they were back
in office by S voting by
7:30 I think that's Mighty brave because
they're going my life is in danger but I
work for America and you know the clock
don't stop you America First they're
like hey thank God for that curfew
because the Insurrection was it was
curved by the curfew so now we can go
back to
voting we we have some Brave politicians
in our government super Brave you know
to risk death and murder and you know an
armed you know militia you know coming
down on there yeah and be like no we're
going to risk our lives for you because
that's what they're known for being
brave right that's what they did I
didn't know they worked that late to
7:30 crazy I was like normal business
well they had to have like a 5H hour
delay because of the Insurrection makes
you want to pay more tax I know
man stupid AOC had
some [__] bomb ass burritos from
Sonora town the other day and then she
ate a little too much had to go right
you have bubble guts and while in the
middle of there the resurrectionist came
in and they're like I got [__] di of
[__] who's in the bathroom boom boom
boom boom boom and she's like oh my God
someone's trying to [__] kill me but
she just had diarrhea and she wanted to
go to the bathroom really bad when you
got to go you got to go and so they I
think their fear was legitimate but
people weren't trying to kill anybody I
think it was just a lot of people they
were out in the cold at the Trump rally
and they there was no
bathrooms and a lot of people had to
take a [__] and everyone one said the
White House has the nicest
toilets I heard they got warm but
Cedar the nice hand towels this is our
level of
propaganda that's why we're demonetized
this is the reason why I watch mat's
video and I'm like I say the same
[__] [__] but people call me
crazy it can't be your
delivery you know I think I I recently
became more political too I would say
probably even up to co I didn't really
give a [__] cuz it didn't feel like
politics really affected my life didn't
feel like like you know growing up like
even in elementary school you would vote
and then you would like oh who's voting
whatever and you would see who won or
whatever and you just felt like you're
voting for who's like prom king or prom
queen and my whole life it didn't feel
like whoever was in power was going to
have a direct effect until the whole Co
stuff came around then they're like this
state's shut down that one's not shut
down this one has to do whatever these
people need vacc these ones you don't
need like know then that's when I
started getting like I'm like okay if
this is going to have a direct effect on
me that's when I started looking into it
more and more and more I'm like oh [__]
there's 50 states and not all of them
operate the same and not even cities
within the same States operate the same
what the [__] is going on and I would
probably say in the last three or four
years is when I got the most into
politics whereas before it was just like
I don't give a [__] I don't care well
also also I think like the military does
a good job to get you to be a good
soldier so I think like you you you were
also military you also believed in the
government the system and all that and I
think it's it's difficult to go outside
of that too well also like the military
I think most people it's like yeah
you're you're not viewing things from a
political aspect cuz the president
regardless of the Democrat Republican
they're the commander-in chief very for
country and it's for the country so it's
for like a a ideal ethos that isn't like
yes you know there's political
corruption just even as a kid growing up
listening like rage against machine all
that stuff and like you know NW whatever
but you're like it we we can't lower our
own common denominator to match what's
going on you always have to fight for
what's good so I think most people that
join the military regardless it's if you
have a person that's on the right or
left in power you're like I don't really
give a [__] I just want to fight for
what's good and fight for the country so
that it's like more of a idealistic
mindset but even then it didn't really
matter if like which president was a
commander-in-chief cuz we're going to
war anyways and then it wasn't really
until like like literally three or four
years ago as a civilian and then just
seeing how your life cuz I don't know if
you guys remember but La had a curfew
and I'm like what the [__] is this yeah
and I drove during the curfew like bad
ass two like two two gallons of milk per
family and I was like dude this is
[__] crazy and then my gym got shut
down and I'm like what the [__] and
that's when I really started getting
into it yeah I mean the solution would
have been get outside hit get the gym be
more active and that will and get more
healthy that will prevent how Co hits
you that was the solution everyone knows
that now but for them like no like you
got to lock in doors and uh you can't
see anybody you can't go to your
grandmother funeral you can't go to your
friend's wedding like it was so weird
can't see your dad die in ICU and the
and the weirdest part was when people
started turning on each other like hey
my neighbor is having a party you know
they're they're having a super spread
event next door and when when I saw
people start turning on each other and
start reporting each other I was like
dude this is [__] that's a North Korea
baby once it once people started having
emotional reactions to things is when I
was like what the [__] is this it's a
wild time dude it is a wild time um but
I think I'm personally libertarian so
I'm far right but I think the world
needs communism so I'm far left too and
then you put me in the middle I'm
moderate because I'm just like oh that's
how you're moderate well cuz
realistically the common denominator the
average human being is [__] so stupid
they need strict government they need
Draconian hardcore you [__] [__]
this is these are the rules stick with
it okay cuzz you can't control yourself
you you don't have the discipline that's
what I need that's what I need but I do
believe in a awesome libertarian society
around people who are at that level
where I'm like okay you guys are decent
human beings you probably don't need
government to tell you what what to do
if we could create a community of solid
moral human beings that's great but I
just don't [__] trust the billions of
people out there to manage themselves
correctly I agree with you I feel like
if there's a country right and there's a
Dunkin Donuts on every corner if the
whole neighborhood gets fat you guys
need [__] communism you do every time
they touch a donut chop off a hand but
if there's a [__] thing a dunky
Donuts on every every corner and
everyone has a six-pack they're like ah
you guys are libertarian go you guys are
cool you I would say there's no general
rule but you got to assess the people
man systems work in other countries
because the people there are better like
they'll be like what about the
Scandinavia [__] it's all
[__] intelligent ass One race people
dude like that shit's not going to
[__] work here you know like that's
my favorite yeah Scandinavia doesn't do
that Scandinavia socialism works yeah
but you know doesn't work [__] Cuba
dude like why stupid
[Laughter]
ass